[Music]
if you really wish to be
influential if you want to change the
direction of things
if you're interested in actually having
an impact
over time you must know the fundamentals
this graduate school
was inspired by george washington to
teach the large
things that a statesman would need to
know to govern this country well
and it will mostly be taken by people
who work in the government
i am passionate about the future of our
country i think we are in a crisis
moment
and that's why i'm here in politics what
drives me is being part of restoring
self-government in america
what makes me most passionate is the
pursuit of truth
i move to d.c because i really care
about the family
the larger issue area that i'm mostly
focused on is religious liberty
it's our first liberty we want to help
you to be very good at your particular
job
but to be great at that to really be
excellent
it's a matter of knowing what are the
fundamental principles that ought to
inform what i am doing
that's a different way of thinking about
politics most
master's degree programs in washington
dc are kind of on the smorgasbord model
where you take a little bit of that a
little bit of this
count up 36 credits and you have a
master's degree
the master's degree at the van andel
school of government is different
they'll start with plato and aristotle
herodotus and thucydides
and they'll learn what politics is
and then they'll learn what america is
i really love the opportunity to read
primary texts you're reading
what people actually wrote you're
understanding them on their own terms
the pursuit of knowledge is priceless
it's
feeding my curiosity in a way just
nothing ever has
classes are small in size which means
there's a lot of discussion
about things that matter the reading is
challenging but it's also
inspiring and it's reading that you want
to do i don't think i've thought about
statesmanship as much as i have in this
program
you think of lincoln you think of george
washington these people had built up
their understanding and their talents
so that when that moment came they were
shaping
the future of the country
our master's degree is still a hillsdale
education it's still the mission of
hillsdale
but it's designed practically it's put
together in a way that
works well with people in their careers
working during the day so our classes in
our evening
we do some things on the weekends having
the master's program
located on capitol hill is a huge
advantage
that lets us draw from a host of
talented leaders
who are actually practicing the art of
government
we have had senators teach about the
senate
we have had people who are appointees
from the administration talk to us and
teach us about administrative law
dc is a very busy place it can at times
be a very hectic place hillsdale's
program it's for people who
want to apply what they learn here in
their professional lives
i work in the senate buildings just a
block and a half from here so when i get
off work i'm able to walk right over
and be here in time for classes that
begin in the evenings the location
of the kirby center is right in the
heart of washington dc at union station
so it's accessible
anywhere you are across the city i have
so much respect for all the other people
in my classes
they're business leaders they work in
government
so when it comes time to talk in class
it's always
a vigorous and robust discussion you
learn through conversation
it's not just through reading and
thinking on your own
friendship is an essential piece
it's provided a great backdrop and kind
of a shared set of interests and beliefs
and
and knowledge to take that into our
daily jobs and be able to do those even
better i think
because of hillsdale's program
it is an integrated experience you know
from your professional life to what you
learn
and from what you learn to your
professional life at hillsdale i'm not
just a number
i'm a scholar i'm a future statesman and
they have an interest
and an investment in me and in my
education
to be a fine human being you need to
have good character you need to
understand
the ultimate purposes of life and
everything else
and then you'll be equipped to go out in
the world and make some decisions
knowing the principles at the core of
what you're doing will
change how you look at the practical
work you're engaged in because now your
practical work will have a
a much higher and a much deeper
meaning and ultimately in the long run
that's the most
important thing for your success
you